hey guys what's up welcome to D LM model
lifestyle where we give you the best
tips on grooming fitness style and
modeling life I'm Daniel and in this
video we are going to answer one of your
questions some of you asked Daniel how
do you get a slimmer face or your
jawline to really show well that is what
we're going to talk about in this video
and we are starting right now
[Music]
all right now how do you get a slimmer
face and your jawline to really show
well the first step is probably bits
that you won't like that much you have
to lose the fat yes the fattier face but
that also means the whole fat in your
body because if you try to lose just the
fat in your face like doing facial
exercises that's not gonna work if you
lose the fat in your whole body your fat
percentage drop and then you'll see your
fat in your face getting less and less
and less and then your jawline will
stand out more and more and more because
that fat is not there to cover it my
second tip is for guys with beards if
you have a beard just shave it the right
way there's a lot of guys who just leave
these neck hair here and the hair here
and it's just all over the place so what
you want to do is you want to shave
these neck hair off you want to start
here with your jawline here and shake
close here to your chin and then back
this way as well and then these hair
here on your cheek you want to remove
that and then you can see if your beard
is shaped nicely your jawline is gonna
stand out a lot better alright
the third tip is for those guys who
normally shave if you always shave but
you want a really nice jawline you might
want to grow out your beard if you grow
a beard it would look like you have a
nicer and stronger Joe line there's
actually a lot of guys that looks better
if they have a nice beard compared to
when they are shaved all right now let's
move on to number four there's a lot of
people that say if you do certain facial
exercises the muscles in your face gets
stronger and so your jawline looks as if
it's bigger and stronger right okay
let's talk about those exercises number
one if you blow wind on the left and the
right side in the front and you hold it
there for ten seconds that's one
exercise and it looks like this and then
to the front and then to the right so it
looks like that okay that's the first
exercise the second exercise is it one
where I'm gonna show it from the side so
you can have a look is you bring your
your head up a little bit and what you
want to do is you want to bring these
lower jaw bone and you want to move it
forward
so you do it like this
[Laughter]
you see that I would suggest you not to
do that because number one you look
stupid
all right I just yeah number two
wrinkles actually comes from repeated
muscle action so you will actually look
older a lot quicker so don't do it some
people say that if you chew chewing gum
it will also help you now when I was
younger I used to chew a lot of chewing
gum and I used to chew at the back of my
mouth here and I could feel how tired my
mouth would get because I chewed a lot
and then after a while I could see the
difference it was getting a little bit
bigger now some people try to chew
chewing gum but they say it's not
working and maybe it's because people
chew it differently some people chew
more like camels like like like that
some people more like mouth I don't know
maybe it's about the way people chew the
chewing gum I don't know give it a try
if it works it works if it doesn't work
it doesn't work but the best tip really
is just to lose the weight if you lose
the weight you will see a nicer jawline
and you will have a slimmer face now if
you liked the video give me a thumbs up
subscribe so that you won't miss any of
my new upcoming videos and that's it
just guys